thank you
[Music]
welcome back to care for boys we're very
careful boys today we're talking about
are you guys how do you feel about open
relationships Nick Dunn open
relationships I could ever do one just
your general thoughts General thoughts
judge people if you need to uh if I'm
being judgmental yes judgmental side and
a non-judgmental side can I do that yeah
I think from what I've seen from
observations what I'm being judgmental
close range observation I feel like it
takes a very specific yeah five mile
radius
non-consensual uh open relationships
like I don't want it but my wife wants
it so you gotta deal where's your wife
want to do
um I think it does take a very specific
type of person two specific type of
people to be able to have an open
relationship I think it is pretty hard I
don't think I could ever do it I wonder
the SEC the success rate I don't think
it's that high yeah because like well
what's the intention right are you
trying to uh trying to [__] you're
trying to [__] right that's what it
really I almost feel like that's easier
though if it's open relationship or it's
like open [__] versus actual open
relationship I think it's hard to like
confide and have like uh emotional
intimacy with like five people versus
like this is my partner we both [__]
around and we come back to each other
because it's physical I feel like that's
easier because everyone else is like
technically masturbation but just with
the other humans yeah but then here is
like our relation or whatever yeah how
do you find the time that's that's the
other side of the equation too please
find time for things you love doing
because even in polygamous right like
when you when you watch those shows with
uh your shoes
when you watch those like polygamous
shows right yeah that the husband looks
[__] drained like he's never sleeping
and then the all the wives are fighting
for attention and then like he wants you
know he gets to sleep with this one but
then they're just sleeping and cuddling
like they're not banging every night you
know and then like sometimes he's gonna
buy a flower store dude this guy's going
broke I think it's for rich people
sometimes too yeah you definitely have
to have a
foreigner with a lot of resources he's
farming tulips and [__] he's rich in
resources rich in time as well too
vagina you know if you want to know uh
swimming in it I guess this would be
like a preconceived or like bad
stereotype I have about it is only
because I've seen this
like you said it takes two people that
have that unique
um thing where they both want to do it
yeah but I've seen too many situations
where dudes be talking their girl into
doing it and making them think that they
also wanted it yeah yeah
right it's like the manipulation I've
seen the opposite and that [__] yeah the
girl makes the guy and we know someone
that's tough like that not to name names
but she is the one that convinced her
husband at the time to have an open
relationship Jill would convince me
[Laughter]
yeah we all we all knew that she's
already had the relationship that's why
she was living with the guilt and
convinced of the open relationship so
she could freely have her boyfriend
right
went off to Europe lived with her
boyfriend while her husband was paying
for the trip so she's trying to get a
receipt for some she already stole
basically so oh that's so good then this
guy's good he's like well [__] it and
he's acting out on it and then she gets
jealous comes back
and then wants a divorce all this stuff
they get a divorce
and then
um you know her husband like or
ex-husband just kind of
you know go single and he actually finds
a genuine relationship and she gets
extremely jealous because her you know
her her boyfriend leaves her and she's
all single and all this stuff and he
might have been like the best he never
happened to her when she [__] it all
away yeah yeah that's another thing too
right because I think the grass is
always greener right you think it's oh
man I'm gonna be able to find someone
out there and then once you go start
going through the motions of that you
realize like oh what I had at home was
actually way more ideal because it's
also I think the grass is greener where
you water it too right like if you put
time and effort inside a relationship
that's when it gets
the ideal relationship that you're
looking for versus oh I could just go
get it out there
but I haven't been in that situation my
wife [__] around a lot and she's she's
out there searching dude yeah yeah yeah
it was uh this one guy was talking about
that right and then he was like you know
what where a lot of guys [__] up is like
they're trying to fill up that 10 that
they're missing in their relationship
with this other person because she'll
have the 10 percent
because he'll like take for granted the
90 that he's getting fulfilled from his
current wife so he leaves the 90 and the
children and everything and that to
fulfill that 10 and he looks back like
[__] yeah I had it so good why were
people raised with guilt I was Raising
so much Soul crushing yeah for real
there's no way I could even [__] even
think about opening my relationship up
first of all second of all I probably
couldn't even get hard if I was with
some chick because I'd be so [__]
thinking about Nikki the whole time and
how I'm [__] betraying her yeah
I think it's not so much yeah but I
think it's uh the lack of discipline and
their impulses are stronger than their
guilts so like for example I think a lot
of people do feel guilt after the fact
they do it they talk themselves into it
but it's like a kid that loves chocolate
don't cry while they like went into the
chocolate jar it's like the dog is so
cool with chocolate they're on the
ground
I think that their level of whatever it
is the need to they might also see it as
a form of Liberation too because like
you know like when you grow up and
you're like [__] all I've been doing
this what my parents [__] want and
then you have guilt when you're doing
what your parents don't want you to do
but then you finally do it and they're
like [__] yeah I'm my own person so I
could see that too where they're like my
whole life I was being told to do this
but I've always been feeling this way
and then so when they go and they do it
they might actually feel like ah I'm
free for once I think it's great when
you find the example of two people that
both really like it but I never found
nobody yeah yeah I don't know any
situations where yeah it's always like
one person's convincing the other that's
the hard part I always see it on Vice
it's like some couple everyone has
tattoos a lot of tattoos and they're
like and then like yeah we're it's great
actually it's [__] awesome and [__]
like but right honey right yeah Shannon
um
Budram she has an opening relationship
that she never acted out on yeah but
their policy at home is both of them can
be open and the both of them have not
acted I think that happens a lot though
too because it's like if you have that
free pass and you have that
so
don't want to do it yeah
but isn't that weird too it's like
so like say I'm at JK or whatever and
there's some chick or something and then
I already know I have an open
relationship with Nikki and then but
like I haven't used it yet but then like
tonight she's like hey where are you at
and I'm like oh like um there's this
cool chick of JK we're gonna go get
dinner yeah right it's weird also I also
feel like it's like but yeah logical
denial though but that does work in a
situation where if if Nikki was the kind
of girl that thought it was hot to think
of you and another girl that's where
that's where it's like oh that's because
it only works if the person's a cup
that's what I mean there are couples
that like the idea of their mate with
another person
it's getting real I actually had a open
relationship like
um situation where it was just like yeah
we we just don't talk about whatever but
it only worked because there was no love
in the relationship
it was a very convenient relationship
with it was more like a roommate
situation where we're friends that [__]
right so there's no like deep feelings
no and I had no sexual jealousy so I was
like yeah [__] whoever you want so a
loving open relationship is what we're
talking about like I think that that's
difficult that's very different very
very different how did you not have some
type of feeling you know especially if
you love somebody and then they're just
getting because that's almost like like
hey I love I really love this car and
then you just leave the keys and
everybody can come drive
[Laughter]
it's like usually the more the things
you love the most are the most sacred to
you and then you're like you're trying
to protect it and nurture it as much as
you can it's hard to be like oh I love
this theme but yeah everyone everyone
take a drive yeah come on that's why
usually when when there's people like
that in your life that end up in stuff
like this you kind of have to if it's
someone close to you you can kind of see
they grew up with a different definition
of love that's true something was
different love was expressed differently
in their household love was expressively
growing up it's never like your normal
thing so that's how they ended up
arriving at like a more custom version
that's true because I know someone who
probably wouldn't even mind being
cheated on if they were a stable good
like husband
and then it's because of how she was
raised and what was normal in her
household and her mom was like a side
chick and so like all those and then so
like yeah she's in these very like weird
relationships all the time and and I
feel like she's desensitized
um and very accepting of the like the
very liberal like you know ways of
viewing sex so like I think well you
know in these open relationships
can you one love multiple people
simultaneously and give them all the
same level of attention like that's hard
to do right so that's why I think the
rest of us are constantly equating it to
like
sexually open
but some people will use that definition
and go open relationships means no I
couldn't deeply care for and feel
romantic and maybe they can
maybe they can I just can't relate to
that or maybe maybe it's the environment
that's dependent right like you know you
hear some people that live like a
polygamy like household and it's like
eight people that live in a house or
something sister wife stuff yeah like
and it's equal guys whatever whatever
the setup is I feel like because the
environment of the whole Community is
like in on it maybe they're normal yeah
maybe that'll work in addition to that
way oh yeah or like lifestyle yeah like
let's say like uh pre-taika if me and
Jill are together but then it's like I'm
on tour all the time
and then we also want to have like
physical needs met then we have this
thing that's cool but then we're still
each other's per like person I can
totally see that yeah but then I I think
for me personally like once uh taika's
in the picture like I love this Dynamic
so much there's no way but the previous
like we've talked I think the similar
topic before it has been brought up I
could see ourselves maybe being open
like maybe later on and being like
physically open uh or whatever but once
we had like tight gun that there's like
so many other domino effect beings that
could happen it's just too this is too
risky I think he comes home and I know
his cheeks been clapping around for
somebody else I I think it's over yeah
actually my brain caves in and then like
Nick Don I think it's murder suicide
murder homicide you want to know that I
take the cats with me too you want to
know sick ass detail though I think the
couples that are doing this well and are
having no problems I don't think you'll
ever hear about it yeah why because it's
part of their identity [__] works the
people people that are trying to justify
to the World by going hey look at us
we're doing good we're advice they're
not doing good like virtues saying
million their own way exactly because
because one of my one of my really
closest friends she found out way later
in life that her parents were like that
wow but it was way later it was quiet
she was already [__] an adult she's
in her 30s she came home at the wrong
time oh [__] and her parents were they
were swinging they had another couple
over and then her mom had to explain to
her like honey this is like our
lifestyle we've always kind of been this
way oh yes one of your Lifestyles and
they're like some Orange County like
white like white bread really really
great family what the [__] are they but
they don't they just do them in the
living room if you could just come home
and be like this is weird if I just see
my parents with like two other parents
just [__] away yeah it must be
something like that
with a spread like a mommy was topless
and you know some shitri board out
you're like it was a party but they're
[__] clapping cheeks in the master
bedroom that does sound like some OC
conservative like yeah but they're not
they're not out there trying to Advocate
it they're just they just do it and it
was a rotisserie probably because they
don't publicize it also it seems like
they're doing that experience together
exactly open a relationship and you're
individually going you're separate yeah
yeah that's an orgy to prove it to other
people that's when it's that's like I
think a bad sign that's like people with
miserable bomb Point that's like
miserable relationships that need to
compensate with big expensive weddings
oh yeah very true yeah it is
you're overcompensating dude Kim K
Marion uh what's his name the the
basketball player Oh freeze and then
like divorce oh my God in a month yeah
they spent like two million five million
dollars but they they [__] made it
back though because all the brand deals
oh that's right right that [__] was
crazy crazy yeah but you know hang on my
thread though so it's a no for me I've
got it
that's that is like the call center guy
we're like he's like hello I work for
the Best Buy and then you like [__] you
he's like [__] you [__] you
that's you getting you getting a gorilla
wedding and then like you're divorced in
a month
same exact thing bro I think if tip ever
found out I was like I was like sleeping
around or doing something crazy I think
she would literally kill me yeah I think
she'll slip my [__] into it yeah for
sure absolutely I think the idea if it
all works out perfectly seems fine right
but then like
you can't predict how both of you will
react and it's one of those things you
can't change once you open that door
yeah that's true that's true you can't
restore it back to the default settings
it might be like you imagine it being
cool and then you open it and you're
just like [__] now I just don't see you
the same way or
you might run into a dangerous human
being and like that's the thing is like
it only takes one sociopath in your life
to [__] ruin everything yeah that's
true you know what I mean like you just
don't know how many stories we cover on
JK where the [__] happens every other
time yeah and then we say that should
happen to them yeah and imagine if like
you get someone pregnant or your wife
gets pregnant or like STD STD just or
just yeah as the older you get the more
like
the like the older you get the more
[__] more reasons to not do it well
there's like extra [__] so like let's
say I had an extra girl on the side and
he got serious
um hey can we add her to our insurance
premium
you just got like you're just cool you
have like all kinds of weird [__]
there's a lot what are the limitations
there's a there's the third person I
want to add to our car registration they
drive it sometimes but you know when you
hear stories about like what the [__] do
you hear stories about a guy that has
like two other families oh that's
[__] crazy that blows my mind right
because it's like how do they do Uncle
convinced my mom that my dad had two
families like years
well my uncle can convince my mom
anything because it's her brother and
like it doesn't take him long and my mom
was fully [__] convinced like serious
or was he like dead serious what are the
signs he was he was serious like he
really I think if he was [__] around
I mean he's a master troll does he hate
your dad or something yeah him and my
dad have like a [__] thing
they have family in America what because
they worked in um shipping so and then
he you know he was a traveling like
pastor and [__] so like he had a family
out there in Wales and then when he came
to the states he had another one here in
Utah whoa yeah and then they did it
23andMe and all that they were just like
we have family out there and then like I
guess they all reached out on like
Facebook and whatever see that makes
swinging look like easy mode yeah yeah
yeah yeah family yeah that's tough bro
the other [__] pictures of Diablo
that's exactly what that's like
trying to do that well yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah the best thing about
Nikki is she knows how to push my
buttons like nobody else on the earth
and if I cheated on her or something
[__] up like that I know exactly what
she would do to me and it would [__]
actually melt my soul I could actually
cry right now I think yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
you know what she would do she wouldn't
even like she would be mad at me but
that's not what she would come at me
with oh no that's too simple
yeah she's like [__] Dexter dude
she would hit me with the like
disappointed like I'm gonna be okay but
like man I loved you so much oh God down
dude
that hurts way more than blowing up in
my car it's hurting me it's not even a
relationship more because then you just
sit with it and you're just it's like
I'm the girl oh my God I'm the guy
sitting in my [__] and pissed yep yep
yep you got nothing to show for it too
right to show for it what I get a blowy
yeah a sad blowy because I'm so scared
and sad took forever too because you
couldn't ever no couldn't even stay hard
yeah yeah that's what man you gotta
watch out like for for girls they gotta
really find that red flag when a dude
starts to kind of push it yeah because
I've seen it pushed in the fashion of
like
um you know like some girls think other
girls are cute and then their dude's
gonna go oh you think she's cute you
think she's hot and then they try to
push this like yeah almost bisexuality
in teams I don't think that works bro as
a as a gateway to getting him so dude
that's a [__] thing I've heard it on
that side I've heard on the guy's side
what do they do for anything
what are they what what do they do it
for they do it to get the pass
eventually passed to them so they'd be
like oh babe you think she's High we
should why don't you just experiment try
it out you know and then that way
there's leverage to go all right now my
turn like why don't I have sex with her
now it's it's [__] disgusting and it
does work that way
and it has worked because you know why
some Partners just want to make them
happy yeah they'll do anything and they
might be a little gay curious we all are
a little gay Curious
George yeah that's just admit it Joe you
said that we had to be to work here yeah
that was a prereq that's why I'm here
my conversations are way more boring
it's like did you see rib eyes are on
sale at Albertsons
should we go there
[Laughter]
they actually turn the Earth more than
me part nothing
[Music]